when john wick enters a room of enemy
combatants within seconds he must
prioritize which targets present the
most immediate threat
and in which order to dispose of them
boom
boom boom he picks off each one with
precision
but then more combatants burst in
through the door and let rip with a
round of automatic fire
now he must locate cover and move to it
in the fastest most unpredictable way
possible
this relies on visual processing and
working memory he must have created and
maintained a mental map of this room
based on his superior situational
awareness he must understand where he is
in space
how his weight is distributed and how to
produce enough force to pivot and dive
while taking precise aim
this is multi-sensory integration that
occurs in the parietal cortex
and throughout the rest of the brain
john grabs a soda can and throws it into
the air
drawing fire away so that he can pop out
of cover and take aim
this is decision making and creative
problem solving under intense pressure
wick must do all of this before an
opponent can close their ooda loop
before they can observe orient decide
act
they literally don't know what hit them
this will depend partly on his ability
to stay calm but highly aroused
to achieve a metronomic heart rate and
state of flow
tired and injured john turns a corner
and is greeted with a bystander
he needs to immediately suppress the
impulse to fire relying on his
inhibitory control
an opponent steps out of the shadows in
his peripheral vision john must react to
that input on the very edge of his
visual field
turn and fire he must then do the same
thing again
and again without losing focus and
without tiring
this is psychomotor vigilance back on
planet earth where i spend
little of my time the same skills are
useful for athletes
for surgeons for airline pilots even for
you and me every time we get in the car
or run downstairs
thus we see the inarguable role of
cognitive function
in human performance make no mistake
this is the difference between good and
great athletes
this is what really matters in a high
stakes situation and
i believe this is the future of human
performance
can we train focus reaction times and
decision making the short answer is yes
there's more than enough evidence now to
suggest that this is possible
as for how that part is a little more
complex
we know that the brain is highly capable
of changing shape and adapting to
stimuli
thanks to something called brain
plasticity neuroplasticity but the
challenge with brain training as i've
discussed before
is that it is often too far removed from
the real world situations it's
attempting to prepare the individual for
the perfect example is the dual n-back
test this is a concentration task that
requires the subject to look for spaced
repetitions
of certain sounds or symbols and has
been shown to improve working memory
focus and task switching ability working
memory refers to our ability to hold
information in our mind
so that we can manipulate it we use a
similar skill when we carry over numbers
in maths or
when we remember a phone number to write
it down we see for example that dual end
back tests can improve dual task
performance
this in turn is a critical skill for
athletes but this could be better
dual then back and exercises like it
train the brain in a domain specific
manner
the user is focused on a screen looking
at digits and possibly listening out for
sounds
this is far removed from the way that an
athlete uses their working memory
to maintain a map of the positions of
each player on the pitch and the ball
combining information from multiple
senses whilst also making snap decisions
thus we do not see wide adoption of dual
n-back training
among athletic coaches or military as
with physical training we likely need
greater specificity
to see near and far transfer to other
tasks a more realistic way to bolster
working memory then
may be through 3d multiple object
tracking 3d multiple object tracking is
exactly what it sounds like
a task that challenges the individual to
track multiple objects
as they move through 3d space one study
found that this was more effective than
dual nbac
for improving working memory in another
study a different 3d multiple object
tracking tool
could be used to improve player accuracy
in passing a football
though not in dribbling and shooting
this makes sense if you consider the
importance of working memory
in accurately tracking the positions of
teammates on the pitch
there is certainly scope for tools such
as this in an athletic or military
setting
what's more is that these kinds of 3d
tracking tasks may also be effective for
improving vision this is because they
train visual attention
when you consider the huge amount of
information that comes in through the
human eye
at any one time and the bottleneck in
terms of the amount of information we
can attend to
it's impossible for us to take in
everything at once so instead we must
scan our eyes around and create an image
from piecemeal information
schemas and assumptions much of what we
think we're seeing
is in fact already out of date or
entirely missing or fabricated
this is why working memory is tied so
closely to our visuospatial landscape
our ability to manipulate information in
our mind's eye is the glue that holds
all of this together
this means that we can't accurately
attend to something happening outside
our attention though
creating inattentional blindness this is
a problem if your john wick and a bad
guy just drew his weapon
it's also a problem if you're a driver
and someone steps out into the road
fortunately we have specific systems
that activate in response to movement
sound or contrast and these activate our
salience network
thus directing our attention towards the
changes this is why traditional vision
tests alone
may be insufficient in testing a
person's suitability for driving for
example
especially as we age and our visual
field begins to shrink tracking objects
can help to increase the field of vision
by enhancing perception in the
peripheral vision while at the same time
improving visual processing
allowing more information to be
incorporated and acted upon
plasticity can occur within the visual
cortex and this can even reverse some
vision loss
there are other physical exercises that
could be used to train these skills
bouncing and catching a ball while
keeping the vision fixated on a central
target
is one option likewise dribbling two
balls simultaneously
you can also try bouncing a reaction
ball which is an oddly shaped ball that
bounces erratically
as the user can't predict the movement
of the ball as they normally would
they are instead required to track and
catch the ball juggling may have similar
benefits as the juggler must track the
positions of multiple objects
simultaneously
usually using peripheral vision this has
been shown to actually increase gray
matter in brain regions relating to
sports vision
for the peripheral vision there's the
toothpick and straw method that involves
picking up a straw using two toothpicks
and looking straight ahead but being
able to juggle a lot of information in
the mind's eye see what i did there
is not enough more important is being
able to quickly and effectively act on
that information
this is at least partly dependent on
visual processing speed
the ability to rapidly act on large
amounts of information coming into the
brain
this generally declines as we get older
but perhaps it needn't be so
several studies have shown that visual
processing speed can be enhanced
using computer-based training another
clear example of this is seen in gaming
gamers that play fast-paced fps
first-person shooter games
show a superior ability to make rapid
decisions with no loss in accuracy
they also demonstrate enhanced visual
acuity and spatial awareness
they can even distinguish between
different shades of grey more
effectively
i'd love to see a study on doom internal
in particular
that game forces you to make countless
micro decisions under extreme pressure
for extended periods
in short playing doom eternal could make
you almost as badass as the real doom
slayer
the limitations of a game like this that
of course would be the two-dimensional
and static nature
like dual nbac action games do not
immerse you in the action
or require you to monitor your
peripheral vision to the same extent
the number of inputs is reduced even
more significantly as you aren't
listening to the extremely dense amount
of input
coming from your body this combination
of information creates your visual motor
landscape
and it's not enough to know what's
happening in front of you you must also
be aware of your body's position
and relative distance from the subject
and target this is what allows you to
select the correct action
to leap up and catch the ball or to
quickly grab a trash can lid before a
grenade goes off
being able to calculate the best action
is useless if you can't also
act on that decision a lot of this
relates to what the military describes
as situational awareness
knowledge of what's going on in a
complex dynamically changing environment
another useful method for measuring and
training processing speed
is the simon task the simon task uses
interference to make an otherwise simple
reaction test
more cognitively demanding for example
you might be tasked with clicking right
when you see the word right appear on
the screen and left when you see the
word left
the rub is that occasionally the word
right will appear on the left side of
the screen
and vice versa this is harder than it
sounds and it gets harder as you become
more tired it is not enough to simply
react you must decide how to act
interestingly one study found that
practicing the simon task
could improve a lacrosse player's
ability to target the ideal part of a
goal
this is something we could very easily
emulate in a training environment
by getting a subject to perform one of
two actions depending on the stimuli
and using various methods to interfere
with this message something else missing
from many video games is inhibitory
control
our ability to suppress inappropriate
reactions
the way a game might imitate this is by
presenting hostages and penalizing the
player for shooting them
this can be a very useful tool for
athletes and other high performers
in one study professional athletes
demonstrated superior performance
on a stop signal task this task requires
the individual to react quickly to a
stimulus
unless it is presented alongside a stop
signal a similar concept is the go
no-go task this is a skill that has very
obvious crossover for military personnel
in particular
or john wick in one study it was
demonstrated that actively training
response inhibition
could potentially reduce civilian
casualties the study used a go no-go
task a stop signal task a stroop task
and a visual search task to train
participants i believe this could be
even better if placed into a real
physical environment
developing quick reactions and decision
making and focus is one thing
maintaining that heightened cognitive
performance for long durations
is another the same challenge faces
drivers pilots
and surgeons working 10 hour shifts this
is psychomotor vigilance
but it's not just tiredness that can
cause lapses and focus on reactions
emotional stress can also have a huge
impact which is one reason we often
perform worse when under pressure
meditation has been shown to enhance
psychomotor vigilance
countless studies show how this can
result in greater emotional control
as the individual learns to ignore
distracting thoughts and feelings
but the military has another approach to
this one that's a little more
insidious the hooded box test is a test
that places the trainee
under a hood that completely obscures
their vision and hearing
this hood is then removed revealing a
unique scenario
often this will be a combat scenario
requiring target prioritization
and rapid action but alternatively it
might be a woman asking for directions
the candidate must respond to the
situation in seconds this not only
challenges decision making
action inhibition and situational
awareness but also requires performance
in a high stress scenario
the test is designed to trigger a fear
response in the subject and over time
this is thought to desensitise them to
those emotions and thus reduce
the lag time that an emotional response
can induce
this may correlate with increases in
dhea in the brain and
neuropeptide y we could easily
incorporate something similar into
athletic training
throughout this video i have pointed to
a number of options for improving
reactions
focus and decision making one of the
most important takeaways though is that
sports themselves can improve a number
of cognitive abilities
meanwhile athletes themselves could
benefit from focusing on those same
abilities
focus visual processing task switching
object tracking impulse control and more
so too could gamers but perhaps the most
promised to my mind
lies with virtual reality
virtual reality has the flexibility to
create extremely cognitively demanding
challenges
in short it can do everything a regular
video game can but in a 3d space that
allows full freedom of movement one
company neurotrainer
has already seized this opportunity with
react performance trainer
this is a fully 3d brain training tool
for the quest in quest 2.
the game ostensibly involves blocking
and dodging projectiles
but there's a lot more going on under
the hood these projectiles for instance
are fired from targets that must be
constantly tracked
as they move rapidly around the screen
and hide among identical looking
distractors
meanwhile you are tasked with pulling a
trigger to slow the movement of the
harmful shots
but must refrain from doing so for the
other balls it cleverly integrates the
most useful aspects of the go no-go task
3d object tracking tasks a psychomotor
vigilance task and more
the promise is that with time you should
start to notice gameplay seemingly slow
down during sports
real bullet time awesome you can get the
app on the quest store right now
and i highly recommend it to athletes
pro gamers and anyone interested in
being batman
hands up if that's you i'll put a link
in the description down below
this is not a sponsored post by the way
i just love it
as it turns out though react is actually
just the consumer release and consists
of just a single simplified skill
taken from a far more comprehensive
suite of tools called neurotrainer
the neurotrainer system boasts a
sensitive measurement and layered
cognitive analytics platform
a broader package of precise training
skills and is in use by athletic teams
and even has the interest of the
military
who use it to improve decision speed
task switching
focus and endurance or psychomotor
vigilance
i leave you with the amazing ability of
chimpanzees to radically outclass humans
in tasks that measure working memory the
prevailing theory is that humans have
lost this capability
through a cognitive trade-off we
apparently swapped this photographic
memory for a more useful abstract
reasoning but i wonder if perhaps it's
not simply that we stopped training this
ability
a chimpanzee will spend its entire day
in a group of other chimps
it will move through the trees and chase
food tracking objects and predicting
their movements is an ability it will
train
the entire day every day if we did the
same thing
could we maybe achieve the same
superhuman memory
who knew that the real life john wick
was actually a chimp
i hope you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share around that helps
me out
immensely thank you so much for all your
support and all your comments and
everything you always do
it always helps a great deal there's a
written version of this video on the
website as usual with a lot more
information and links to
all of the studies to back the stuff up
this to me is a really fascinating area
of fitness and training and
human performance and i think it's going
to be a big topic in the coming years
let me know what you think in the
comments down below if you'd like to
learn more about functional training and
improving your performance
in a real-world and athletic setting
then check out my book
functional training and beyond which is
available right now in the us in most
good book stores including amazon of
course i'll put links to that in
description down below
and it'll be available here in the uk on
the 19th of february so not long at all
alternatively if you want a training
program that incorporates everything
from
brain training to breathing to strength
training to mobility
then check out my ebook and training
program super functional training i'll
put a link to that in description down
below as well and there's a discount on
that right now
while so many of us are still stuck in
lockdown subscribe if you want more like
this and hit the notification button if
you want to be notified of future
uploads thanks again so much for
watching and i'll see you next time
bye for now